("Ukraine has surprised the world.
Ukraine has inspired the world.
Ukraine has united the world.
There are thousands of words to prove it,
but a few will suffice.
HIMARS, Patriot, Abrams, IRIS-T, Challenger,
NASAMS, Leopard")
Vladimir Putin thought it would be a matter
of a few hours.
That in just a few days Ukraine would be fully
under his control.
According to his plans, the Russian army would
advance at full speed and would occupy Kyiv
within a few days.
Zelenskiy and his government would abandon
the capital, the Ukrainian army would surrender
and everything would be ready for the victory
parade.
Putin would have his great military feat and
Ukraine would be back under the thumb of the
Russian Motherland.
("We also found some parade uniforms there,
so they expected to get Kyiv in two days and
then have a parade here.
So we can say now that we have completely
destroyed their plans."
Oleksandr Hruzevych, the Deputy Chief of Staff
of the Command of the Ground Forces of Ukraine)
However, the course of events could not have
been more different: The Ukrainians held out
against all odds, international aid arrived
on an unimaginable scale, and the Russian
army turned out to have more holes than a
Swiss cheese.
The result?
Not only was there no victory parade, but
one year later the war rages on and Russia
has suffered an enormous number of casualties,
both in terms of equipment...
As well as men.
According to existing estimates, more than
180,000 Russian soldiers were killed or wounded
during the first year of the invasion alone.
We are talking about an average of almost
500 casualties every day.
What’s more, in just 12 months of war, the
Russian army has lost more generals and high-ranking
officers than in seven years in Syria or than
the Soviets did during their 10-year war in
Afghanistan.
And to make matters worse, the casualties
have hit many of Russia's best-trained units,
such as the airborne troops and naval infantry.
But that's not even the end of it.
Check out this news item:
(Russia Likely Lost More Than Half of Its
Tanks in Ukraine, Estimates Show.
– WSJ)
We are talking about more than 2,300 tanks.
In total, according to the count carried out
by British intelligence, Russia could also
have lost more than 4,500 armored vehicles
of all types, 63 aircraft, 70 helicopters,
12 naval vessels and hundreds of artillery
systems.
And this is only taking into account the losses
that are relatively well documented.
In other words, a real disaster.
To give you an idea, despite all its attempts
and to the astonishment of all NATO armies,
Russia was not even able to take Kharkiv,
a city located only 50km, that’s around
30 miles from its border and one of its main
targets during the invasion.
Yes, so let's make no mistake.
It is true that with his missiles and artillery,
Putin is destroying Ukraine – cities like
Mariupol, Severodonetsk, Irpin, Popasna or
Bakhmut prove it.
But do you know what?
Despite all the losses suffered by the Russian
army, Putin has not achieved a single one
of his main objectives:
Zelenskiy's government seems stronger than
ever, the supposed unification of the Slavic
nation has been a resounding failure, Ukraine
has not fallen and to top it off, its ties
with the West are much stronger and its army
is much better armed.
(Our faith has grown stronger.
Our morale has been reinforced.
We endured the first day of a full-scale war.
We didn't know what would happen tomorrow,
but we realized for sure: every tomorrow is
worth fighting for!
And we fought)
Now, does all this mean that Russian dictator
Vladimir Putin might be willing to give in?
Well...
It certainly doesn't look like it.
One year after the invasion, according to
British Defense Secretary Ben Wallace, Russia
currently has 97% of its combat forces deployed
in the Ukrainian war.
Despite this, neither side seems to have victory
in its grasp.
Neither the Russians nor the Ukrainians.
So the question is, how on earth is this hell
going to end?
How can the war in Ukraine be brought to a
close?
What scenarios are on the table for the major
international organizations?
Well..., let's take a look.
(LOOKING FOR THE EXIT DOOR)
In early October 2021, a very important meeting
was held in the most important office on the
planet: the Oval Office.
Among others, the meeting was attended by
US President Joe Biden, CIA Director William
Burns, White House National Security Advisor,
Jake Sullivan and the Chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff of the Armed Forces, General
Mark Milley.
What was the reason for the meeting?
Well...
Basically to analyze the latest intelligence
information indicating that Vladimir Putin
might be about to invade Ukraine.
We are not talking about conjecture but about
information.
The risk was absolutely real.
We are talking about the beginning of October
2021, almost five months before the Kremlin's
troops finally launched themselves on Ukraine.
At that meeting, as confirmed by Milley himself,
four lines of action were agreed upon:
First, an armed conflict between Russia and
NATO had to be avoided at all costs.
Second, in the event of war, everything possible
should be done to contain it within the geographical
boundaries of Ukraine.
Third, the strengthening and cohesion of NATO
was key.
The phone had to be picked up as soon as possible.
And fourth, and possibly the key point, not
only of the meeting, but of everything we
have experienced since: Ukraine had to be
empowered and given the means to fight.
Yes, VisualPolitik community, that was none
other than the meeting in which the United
States decided that this time it would not
stand in the shadows.
If Russia infringed on Ukraine's sovereignty
and freedom, Ukrainians would not be left
to their own devices.
That was the meeting at which the strategy
was set, which then gradually evolved and
which, along with the solidarity of many European
allies, and above all, the tenacity, endurance
and courage of the Ukrainians have caused
Vladimir Putin to run into a huge wall.
("One year ago, the world was bracing for
the fall of Kyiv.
Well, I have just come from a visit to Kyiv,
and I can report: Kyiv stands strong!
Kyiv stands proud.
It stands tall.
And most important, it stands free").
Kyiv remains free, international allies have
supported Ukraine, in total they have committed
more than $160 billion dollars in military,
humanitarian and financial aid.
A huge amount of resources that has to be
able to cover the needs of this country until
at least the end of 2023.
("Nobody thought the Russians would start
a medieval war in the 21st century.
This conflict is going to change the face
of Europe as much as World War II did."
James Risch, Republican Senator from Idaho
and member of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee)
But obviously, while the fact that Kyiv is
still free is great news, the war, destruction
and annihilation of lives is still a terrible
scenario.
So the question is, what are the ways out
of the war?
Well, here are four ways the war could be
brought to an end.
Of course, not all of them are equally desirable.
Any one of them, starting with the first one,
would be terrible for everyone.
Listen up.
(1.
LET UKRAINE GO)
Putin was counting on the rest of the world
to do absolutely nothing.
That the rest of the countries would stand
idly by and watch him impose his will on a
country that he himself does not consider
as an independent nation.
And do you know what?
In a way, this could still happen.
Take, for example, the cases of Trump and
his entourage in the United States or Le Pen
in France, who openly speak out against helping
Ukraine.
Of course, let's not fool ourselves, if Ukraine's
supply were to be cut off, sooner or later
Ukraine would most likely end up falling.
Or at best, negotiating a ceasefire, which
would be a victory for Putin and a disaster
for Ukraine.
In fact, Western weariness remains one of
Vladimir Putin's greatest assets and explains
in large part why he is still sticking to
his plan.
And that is precisely why Biden's trip to
Kyiv as a clear manifestation of commitment
was so important.
Abandoning Ukraine would mean leaving Ukrainians
under the yoke of Moscow.
Or in other words, facing a lot of repression
and purges of all kinds.
The hundreds of bodies that were, in many
cases, tortured from Bucha and Izyum are a
good example.
But not only that.
It would also be catastrophic for the rest
of the world.
Think about it, we would be telling all the
tyrants on the planet that not only do they
have a free pass to do as they please when
they please, but also that [FATE ACOMPLEE]
fait accompli and the politics of force are
the best guarantee of success.
Now apply that thinking to places like Taiwan,
Korea and Moldova and you have a winning formula
for the worst of all worlds.
("If Putin wins in Ukraine, the message to
him and other authoritarian leaders will be
that they can use force to get what they want.
This will make the world more dangerous and
make us more vulnerable".
Jens Stoltenberg, NATO Secretary General)
This is precisely why this option is completely
ruled out.
("President Putin is confronted with something
today that he didn't think was possible a
year ago.
The democracies of the world have grown stronger,
not weaker.
But the autocrats of the world have grown
weaker, not stronger)
This brings us directly to the second possible
outcome.
(2.
FREEZE THE WAR)
First the Russian offensive and then the Ukrainian
counter-offensives, on the first anniversary
of the invasion, the war was already in a
kind of lethargy...
At least from a territorial point of view.
The major clashes were limited to very specific
points such as Bahkmut.
The Russians have sent many thousands of men
to reinforce their defenses, entrench themselves
and thus try to defend the conquered territory.
It is evident that the casualties suffered
by Russia have been enormous.
But Ukraine has also suffered a huge number
of casualties, both military and civilian,
and although it has received a lot of military
hardware it still does not seem enough to
clearly win the war.
If the allies maintain their support but reduce
deliveries, the conflict could drag on for
years and even freeze completely.
What’s more, the passage of time itself
could favor such an exit.
Exhaustion, fatigue, loss of social and media
attention or the fear of another energy crisis
could lead many countries to end up looking
for a convenient way out, that is, to try
to freeze the conflict and, in a sense, get
back to normality.
Even if Russia ends up launching an offensive,
gains new territories and then asks to reach
a peace agreement, it is possible that many
countries will put pressure on Kyiv to comply.
And do you know what?
Ukraine itself may have no choice but to accept
Russia's presence within its territory and
the permanent sense of fear and frustration
that goes with it.
("We keep repeating that Russia mustn't win,
but what does that mean?
If the war goes on for long enough with this
intensity, Ukraine's losses will become unbearable.
A senior French official told the Wall Street
Journal)
In addition, this would obviously mean much
more pain and much more waiting for Ukrainians,
and it is certainly not clear what future
this country would have.
Could Ukraine really be rebuilt and attract
foreign capital and business if the country
technically remains at war, has part of its
territory overrun and the threat from Russia
remains?
It seems hard to imagine.
And, of course, we cannot overlook the fact
that the Ukrainian economy is in tatters and
its infrastructure is badly damaged.
In other words, that could spell doom in the
medium term.
The inability for the country to ever be viable.
Besides, couldn't Russia resume its offensive
in a few years when Ukraine is weaker and
they have managed to reestablish part of their
military force, even if it is just by training
recruits?
This is a real risk.
In any case it would, in a way, be a victory
for Russia.
A less clear victory, but ultimately a victory.
They would have annexed much of Ukraine and,
in the end, the international community would
not have done much beyond the initial flurry
of action to prevent it.
("Beijing is watching closely, to see the
price Russia pays, or the reward it receives,
for its aggression.
What's happening in Europe today may happen
in Asia tomorrow."
Jens Stoltenberg, NATO Secretary General)
And, take note, because if the arms supply
to Ukraine is not increased this scenario
is quite likely...
And perhaps the best way out for Russia and
perhaps also for Vladimir Putin himself.
That is why some allies, such as Germany or
France, two countries that are not particularly
comfortable with the war – I’ll leave
it to you to guess the reasons – have been
convinced of another alternative, the third
possibility to put an end to the fighting.
(3.
THINKING 2024)
In 2024 there are elections in Russia...
And that is why Putin and his entourage could
be the most interested in reaching a solution
to the conflict before that date.
Lest a military and economic setback, therefore,
call into question his continuity in the top
job in the Kremlin.
That is, if the war is not over...
Many Russian circles could push to get a failed
president out of the way in order to place
a new leader at the helm...
Taking advantage of what would technically
be the end of the Russian president's term.
Well, to avoid such a scenario, Putin might
be willing to negotiate and make concessions.
That at least is what both French President,
Emmanuel Macron, and German Chancellor, Olaf
Scholz, seem to think.
But for all this to be possible, Ukraine must
be in a position to harm Russia...
This requires the rapid delivery of many more
weapons.
Leopards, tanks?
Well, that's the way it's going.
("What we need now is for Ukraine to launch
a military offensive that pushes back the
Russian front to open the way for a return
to negotiations" Emmanuel Macron, President
of France)
And it might not even be necessary to wait
until 2024.
A Ukrainian offensive in the southeast capable
of reaching the Sea of Azov, recapturing the
entire Zaporizhia area and putting Crimea
within artillery range, could be enough to
force a negotiation.
This is what we could call the Big Bang action.
Now, if a negotiated exit is reached...
Can we really trust Russia to keep its side
of the bargain?
Well, the truth is that history tells us that
we can’t.
Ukraine, in fact, is a good example.
Don't forget that Russia itself guaranteed,
in the Budapest Memorandum, the security and
complete sovereignty of Ukraine – including
Crimea – in exchange for Ukraine's surrender
of its nuclear weapons.
Because, remember that upon the dissolution
of the Soviet Union, Ukraine became the third
most heavily nuclear-armed country in the
world.
Therefore, in exchange for these possible
negotiations, Western countries would give
Ukraine much more tangible security: enough
military equipment to discourage any further
Russian aggression in the future: we are talking
about modern armored vehicles, missiles, an
air force, and whatever else is necessary.
An agreement with NATO could even be considered.
And since we would be talking about an agreed
exit, the country could try to get back on
track.
In this way, Ukraine could be shielded and
have a future in exchange for certain concessions
in an agreement that, although bad, would
be much more acceptable than the previous
scenario.
This seems to be, at least, the perception
of the Paris-Berlin tandem, which, according
to what they say today, London does not see
as a bad thing either.
What’s more, Ukraine would not run the risk
of what could happen in 2025 if there were
a change in the White House.
And, take note, because as of today this may
be by far the most likely end to the war.
Of course, there is still another possible
path.
One with many supporters in Ukraine, Poland,
the Baltic States and, also, the United States
of America.
What am I talking about?
Well...
We're going to take a look right now.
(4.
VICTORY AT ANY PRICE)
2023 started with very good news for Ukraine:
We are talking about the commitment to deliver
dozens and dozens, hundreds of armored vehicles
among other equipment...
Including modern tanks.
We're talking, Bradleys, Strykers, Marders,
AMX-10; Challenger II, Leopards, Patriot Batteries,
etcetera, etcetera, etcetera.
If these deliveries are sustained and increased
over time, the course of the war could change
completely.
Especially if more HIMARS, more tanks and
long-range missiles are delivered.
Let alone if they were provided with more
and better aircraft and drones.
And let's see, initially the delivery of weapons
had been very restrained in order, for example,
not to have to accept a defeat against Russia
if Ukraine finally did not withstand the challenge.
And, what can I say, it makes perfect sense,
otherwise NATO would have been badly damaged
and the leadership of the United States would
have been called into question.
Of course, the implications for the rest of
the world would have been enormous.
Now, however, things are completely different.
You see, according to many reports, the Russian
army may be exhausted and under-equipped.
Which would explain why they are having such
a hard time pulling off any offensive.
It is true that Russia has sent many new men
thanks to conscription, but it is also true
that the combat strength of these units does
not seem particularly high.
That is why a succession of strong counterattacks
by the Ukrainian army could blow up the Russian
defense lines.
In other words, there may be a chance to go
all out, defeat Russia and force its army
to retreat and even leave Ukraine, perhaps
with the sole exception of Crimea.
In so doing, the damage to the Putin regime
would be potentially irreparable.
And the question is, but what would it take
to achieve that?
Much more extensive and more determined military
support.
Of course, on the one hand, this possibility
would put the nuclear risk back on the table,
but we already told you about that in a past
video here on VisualPolitik.
We told you why Moscow was unlikely to resort
to that possibility.
Basically because it would gain nothing.
But naturally the risk is still there.
Particularly because this scenario would put
the Russian leader in check.
Obviously losing a war against a much smaller
country with far fewer resources is not a
good thing, even more so when military modernization
and making Russia a strong and great country
again was the Putin regime's No. 1 priority
for more than two decades.
What’s more, if history tells us anything,
it is that it is very difficult for a regime
to survive when it loses a war.
And do you know what?
Despite all the casualties and all the pain
suffered.
This is the option with the most supporters
right now in Ukraine.
(Every Ukrainian has lost someone in the past
year.
A father, a son, a brother, a mother, a daughter,
a sister.
A loved one.
A close friend, colleague, neighbor, acquaintance.
So there you have it VisualPolitik viewers,
these are the four possible scenarios for
us to see the Ukrainian war end.
You can see that in any case the "best" ways
out seem to call for a lot more weapons being
delivered to the Ukrainian government.
This is something that almost everyone seems
to have understood.
Even Olaf Scholz himself.
So now it's your turn:
Which strategy do you think is the most important
to follow?
What would you do if you were calling the
shots?
Leave us your answer in the comments and let's
open a debate.
And now, if you found this video interesting,
don't forget to like and subscribe to VisualPolitik.
All the best and see you next time.